hey youtubers it's Charlie so James done
been dropping all kinds of details about
guardians of the galaxy - including the
script what's in the movie what's not in
the movie so this is gonna be a big
breakdown of that I've also got details
at the end of the video about the new
weekly DC and Marvel giveaways that I'm
gonna be doing all summer long yeah
everybody loves free stuff so what James
Gunn's talking about is he finished the
first draft of guardians of the galaxy -
yeah obviously he didn't he's been
passing it around to the people at
Marvel as well as some of the actors
Chris Pratt said that it made him cry
but he was just talking about the pitch
she wasn't talking about the actual
script he hasn't read the script yet
James Gunn's like one of those directors
that's really open about their process
you know day to day stuff he's really
big on snapchat - of all places which is
kind of funny that script that he just
finished took him about 48 days to
finish which is actually pretty quick
for a movie that big sometimes it can be
a little easier to break sequels just
because you've already created the
universe of the film but like that's
what the first one was all about
creating the universe the guardians of
the galaxy the treatment for the film
which came before the script took him
almost like nine months though the
difference between that in the script is
that the treatment is basically like a
breakdown of all the plot points in the
characters it's like the bones of the
script that you use to sell the film to
executives at Marvel so you say like
this is how the film's gonna go these
are the characters that I'm gonna use
these are the beats the script is like
everything including the actual dialogue
and the stage direction so it's like
once you know what the characters are
gonna do then you decide what they're
gonna say that's probably why it was
easier for him to write the script just
just because he already knows what those
characters are thinking in all their
heads if you already know what they're
thinking then you probably know what
they're gonna say to each other
so the first really awesome thing James
Gunn is not beholden to the same tions
as the other Marvel films are meaning
that there isn't a lot of stuff that
Marvel stuffs into guardians of the
galaxy - people keep asking me questions
about how this is gonna crossover with
the Avengers franchise he said that they
will meet at some point it's really
funny how he kind of like hems and Haws
around that bit it's like yes everyone
understands where this is headed you
know infinity war giant universe
spanning consequences at some point the
Avengers will be in outer space or the
guardians will come to earth and they'll
- no crossover logically you think the
Avengers will go to outer space I think
that'd be more spectacular than the
guardians coming to earth
although at some point you know you
think the Peter quill would return to
earth but before that he has to find his
father and that's what this film is all
about second big awesome detail the film
is all about father's and not just Peter
Quill's father he didn't say this was a
film about shitty fathers but I think
that's implied and in every superhero
movie there's always like a really
crappy dad or a really awesome dad like
you either fall into one or two
categories a lot of the beats will
revolve around Peter Quill's father who
is Jason the spartax in the comics he
already said that that's not gonna be
the case in the movie James Gunn's like
nope no Jason there were a couple
reasons for that
you know most being that he didn't want
other humans in the film like he wanted
Peter quill to be the only human he
wanted him to still feel like a unique
presence in the galaxy like the only
human from Earth
Jason is Bart acts from the sparta
empire they look like they're from earth
so this is too similar adam warlock is
like the highest on everyone's wish list
but the problem is is that the vision
looks a lot like what adam warlock would
look like in a film so they're probably
not gonna use adam warlock in guardians
of the galaxy - i know that's a bummer
because adam warlock possesses the soul
gem in the context of the comics we have
to get the soul gem at some time but
that's probably gonna show up in the
Doctor Strange movie is his eye of
agamotto they did the same thing with
vision in the mind gem so it's like you
know they're kind of mixing and matching
gems from the comics and stuff with the
movies so expect some changes to the
soul gem whenever it shows up just
remember that when Peter Quill's mother
died in the first film
she said that he seemed like an angel
that came down I think the crazy twist
would be if the collector was his father
but let's look at the other fathers in
the group we have Gamora
with Thanos confirmed shitty dad so
obviously the movies gonna push into
that relationship a little bit Karen
Gillan will be back as nebula - you know
complicating that relationship but you
know between the sisters and their dad
they're very very evil dad and just
because the film is about fathers
doesn't mean that it's about all the
Guardians fathers remember Drax the
Destroyers family was killed by Ronan
the accuser he was a father himself so
the film will deal with that too in the
comics he had a more direct relationship
with danos the movie just changed at the
first movie just to make things a little
bit simpler other big shocking twist he
didn't reveal what group was going to
look like at the beginning of the film
remember the last time we saw him he was
dancing baby Groot so radical idea
here the Groot that's in the potted
plant you know like the little dancing
baby Groot that could be son of Groot
so rocket could now be like the
surrogate father of group or group
number two however you want to think
about it if that's the case it'd be a
big change from the comics Groot has the
ability to wreak wrote himself from like
the smallest bit of genetic material he
gets blown up all the time when he does
rocket sticks a little bit of him in a
potted plant you know pour some water on
it and here it grows himself but it's
the same group so like when he
completely regrows himself it's not like
his brain patterns change or anything
like that it seems like based on what
he's saying the group that we meet in
the next film will be the descendant of
the group from the first film even if
that's the case Vin Diesel will still
voice the characters it's not like he's
leaving or anything like that I just
really like the idea of rocket becoming
father of Groot next really big detail
there will be a new character joining
the guardians of the galaxy team like a
new Guardian like I said Peter quill
gonna be the only human from Earth in
the film so the new character that
becomes a guardian joins the Guardians
team will be someone from outer space
he's given no hints as to who that's
gonna be
only that it's not gonna be anyone that
comes from x-men IP and it's not gonna
be Nova he did joke and say that the
Thanos copter was the new Guardian as
much as that's a joke we could see an
Easter Egg for the Thanos copter in the
film and just a case it hasn't been said
before - this film isn't going to be
like a direct prequel to Avengers
infinity war just because it comes so
close to that film in terms of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it's the most
standalone franchise that they have
because it has been so successful if it
had not made so much money I think that
would not be the case the idea is that
you know by connecting all these titles
like you would have a big comic book
event they financially support each
other a little bit because it's like oh
well if this is connected I have to go
see it to understand the story in this
other film the more successful stuff is
the less that's a big deal it's like
okay you know we can just make this
movie it doesn't have to connect people
will go see it no matter what age of
Ultron is like the stark contrast to
that it's set up all the phase 3 movies
Thor Ragnarok Captain America Civil War
all that stuff so when guardians 2 ends
the only thing that it will really be
setting up is guardians 3 you know
because it's a vision as a trilogy
because there's only one more guardians
film before Avengers infinity war we're
probably not going to see that third
film till phase 4 and you
there is a phase four I always get a lot
of questions about that how many phases
is Marvel gonna do like what's gonna
happen after phase three and all the
actors contracts are up remember some of
the actors have already renewed their
contracts they didn't say which actors
but some of the Avengers that started
during phase one will continue to be
Avengers in phase four Marvel will just
keep doing phases until they want to do
a big universe rebooting really like the
logical endpoint for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe before our big reboot
would be Secret Wars like the battle
world stuff that's going on right now
they would just turn that into a film
and use it as a way to reboot all of
their franchises really the thing that I
think we need to be talking about for
this movie is as will Peter Quill's
father be a villain in the movie in the
comics recently his father has become
part of the big black vortex storyline
which I think a lot of people have been
disappointed with but essentially it's
turned his father into an outright
villain that's Jason of spartax he's not
gonna be in the movie but that doesn't
mean that Peter Quill's father in the
movie universe won't be a villain so
here's my really big question for you
guys do you want Peter Quill's father to
be a villain in the movie or do you want
him to be a hero really I think he'd be
a little bit more fun if you were
neutral because he could still be an
and help them and then that's
usually the relationship you see with
people and their fathers and films like
this Howard Stark complete but
he's still viewed as a hero because he
does a lot of good things probably not
the best dad to Tony which is why he has
so many daddy issues same things
probably going to happen with Chris
Pratt's character with Peter quill but
I'm probably gonna do for my next
guardians of the galaxy video is just
like the characters that I want to see
become the new Guardian so be sure to
subscribe to get that if there's any
other guardians videos that you guys
want to see this summer just let me know
in the comments so here's what's gonna
happen with like the weekly Marvel
giveaway this summer I'm gonna be doing
the same thing for DC - just like at
least once a week I'm going to be doing
a giveaway just like I do for Game of
Thrones
or any other big videos if you like
Walking Dead so look for those videos on
Monday and Tuesday I don't know you know
which days which I'll post but it'll be
like whichever first DC video of the
week in whichever first Marvel video of
the week
it's just like how I do you know Game of
Thrones giveaways in the episode video
and then I announce the winner in the
Q&A the next day when we get to
comic-con they'll probably special
editions of all of all these giveaways
because it'll be so much merch
so why you guys wait for that stuff to
post you can click here for the latest
footage from ant-man and you can click
here to learn all about new master
coming to flash C's
- thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you